- Man, this place looks so cool.
- I know it's a huge
studio. We lucked out.
- Yeah, you did.
- Yeah.
It's like a really-
- I mean,
they did probably.
- It's home.
It's home.
So wait, I heard that
being here is a little bit
of revenge for you.
So how so?
- Okay. So when I was young-
(both laughing)
- I love this story already.
- There was this girl,
I was kind of into her
and I was I used to listen
to death medal at the time.
- Okay.
- And so she was like,
"Oh my God, there's this
woman Kelly Clarkson.
She's like, so good at singing.
I love her music."
- I love her already.
- And I was like, "Oh my
God. I love Kelly Clarkson."
I didn't know at the time.
- You didn't even know me.
- So I ended up using you a
little bit at that moment.
(audience laughing)
- Didn't work out for us.
- Okay, okay.
- But I liked your music a lot,
so you stuck with me.
So right now is a really
funny time 'cause,
Sue, if you're out there-
- Look at me now! Look at me now!
(Kelly laughing)
(audience applauding)
That's amazing.
Rub it in.
(Suraj laughing)
So wait, you started acting by accident
which I think is awesome.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's a nice way to do it.
Yeah.
- Well, yeah.
I'm lucky.
I'm like very, very, very,
very, very, very, very, very-
- And very, very, very, talented.
- I'm okay. But lucky really though.
'Cause my brother was
going for this audition
and I was there and I
was sitting on the couch.
I was just like, you know,
supporting him and being like,
"Okay, you do this thing."
I was kind of awkward at that time.
I used to listen to death metal.
- Okay.
We would have been friends,
I was awkward too.
(both laughing)
I'm gonna cover death metal just for you.
- Oh thank you! That
would be (beep) crazy.
(Kelly laughing)
Okay. But, so I'm sitting there.
They're like, "Okay,
it's your turn to read."
I was like, "I'm not here for that."
And they thought I was being
super awkward, you know?
So they're like, "You'll
be okay. You'll be okay.
Just read, just read. You'll be fine."
And I was like, "Oh my God,
I don't wanna talk to you right now."
Plus I was kind of hungover.
(Kelly laughing)
And so I was like, "All right, cool.
I'll read this thing."
Obviously I didn't take it seriously
because like who ever imagines
something like that would
happen to you, right?
- No.
- Not me.
- How mad was your brother?
- Not mad.
He's a good brother.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That is a good brother.
- We stick by each other, always.
- Okay. I'd have been like
a little like, mm-hmm.
- I feel like-
- Mm-hmm.
- I feel like in the
beginning maybe he was like,
" What the hell, bro? This is my thing."
- You just like showed up for support.
- No, but he was very good about it.
- That's cool.
- He's always been very good about it.
- That's awesome.
- And he raps now, so.
- Yeah. Oh, I love that.
God, y'all are just so creative.
He should rap to death metal.
He should come on and we
should both rap to death metal.
- Oh, that would be crazy!
- Oh my God-
- It would be so bad,
but great.
- Some double bass crazy.
(Kelly laughing)
- So congratulations on
"How I Met Your Father."
I am like so happy for you,
but I wondered, did you see
"How I Met Your Mother?"
Did you see-
- Yeah!
- Okay. Did you like that one?
- I did.
- Do you have to say you like it?
(Kelly laughing)
- No, you know what?
It's really funny.
I was pretty cynical
about this being a thing.
'Cause I watched "How I Met Your Mother."
Again, it was because
of a girl, I watched it.
But I ended up loving the show
and I was like, "Oh my God,
this is such a great thing."
So when I found out about this,
I was like, "Okay you
don't wanna, why would you,
like these are big shoes to fill.
Like how you gonna do this?
Don't try to ruin something
that's kind of perfect." Right?
- Sometimes that's the
case, but not always.
- Not always.
I talked to the creators,
I started talking to the actors,
I read the script, and
I started realizing,
it's not like they're trying
to make the same thing again.
They just want that world
to keep existing, you know?
Like "How I Met Your
Mother" was a great world
for people to escape to, you know?
Friendship, love, like
the process of life.
Like living in the moment,
all the crazy things that go down.
It was really fun to watch
and be part of, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So now they're trying to do that again.
- But in this age, in this generation.
and with these people.
And the people are fantastic.
On and off the camera,
just beautiful, beautiful,
beautiful souls, so...
- I love that.
The chemistry, that's so important.
Like people you're working with-
- Good chemistry!
- Yeah. The older I get, I'm like,
I only wanna work with people I like.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I don't have
room for anybody else.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
So wait, you have a nude
scene in one of the episodes.
So was that terrifying?
Or were you just like, "Let's do this!"
Here's something you should know about me.
I actually don't mind, I
don't mind being naked.
Like I think people
are weird about naked.
- Naked.
- Oh, I'm Texan, sorry.
(Suraj squealing)
I don't mind.
I think people get weird,
(Suraj laughing)
they get weird about nakedness
and I'm like, we all have the same parts.
I don't understand
what's so weird about it.
- I agree with you.
There's no problem
with being naked.
- I would go to a nude beach
and be like "Let's do it!"
Like, and I'd be so comfortable.
Like, were you comfortable?
Or were you scared?
- Okay. Here's what's happening?
Like, when I read the script,
I was like, "Oh God, here we go.
Okay. It's happening?
We're gonna be naked."
(audience laughing)
- It's...
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- But the weirdest thing is
I had a lot of fun.
Like maybe, like maybe like
not, it was too much fun.
You know, I was like, okay,
'cause the prop, the prop, the prop
is this thing, right?
It's this?
What do you call it?
A mechanical vagina.
- That's amazing.
This is an amazing conversation.
What?
- Yeah, that vibrates.
(Kelly laughing)
And it looks like-
- Oh my God!
- You know those 1700 scuba helmets
with the mesh on the front?
- No.
- Yeah, you do. You've seen them.
- What?
- I promise you,
you've seen them.
- I don't scuba.
- Nah, but nobody scubas with 1700-
- Wetsuits are like spanks from hell.
- [Suraj] That's not funny.
No, but you know, that little round thing
with the mesh in the front,
people go down, it's like,
(Suraj blowing bubbles)
that thing.
- Mm-hmm.
- You'll get it. You'll see it.
Hopefully you'll see it.
Anyway, I'm wearing this thing
and I'm walking around
with myself in it.
- Oh my God.
- On set.
And I'm just having the best time.
- I love you! That's what I'm saying.
You know what people make it awkward.
- People make it weird.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it doesn't have to-
- I would've been great
in the Garden of Eden
is all I'm saying.
- Yeah, you would.
- I would have rocked those leaves,
or no leaves.